- Viens-- Viens-t'en, on s'en vr
dehors! Go! Allez, vas-y!
On y va dans la cour!
- Catherine Montpe
terrier, en juillet 2020.
Elle l'a payé 2500 $,
parce que c'est un chien rare.
Il est devenu le meilleur ami
de son fils.
- J'ai p, son petit
frère, puis le soir, il va
le border dans son lit,
ils écoutent la télé ensemble...
Il le suit partout, partout, là.
T'es un bon chien!nouveaux chit
été achetés par les Québécois
pendant re année
et demi de pandémie.
- C'est pour l'isolement,
puis la présence que ça fait
dans la maison. Mes pauses,
mes heures de dîner, je viens
rang en arrière avec
quasiment tous les jours.- Seloe
commandé par l'Association des
médecins vétérinaires du Québec,
maintenant un chat ou un chien.
C'est un record.
Claudia Sauvé, la vétérinaire
de Bowser, est débordée.
Clinique Saint-Louis-de-Gonzague
- J'ai vraiment jamais connu
en 11 ans, de carrière, là,
d'avoir des temps d'attente pour
les rendation, avant, ça pouvait
aller dans une semaine,
deux semaines. Maintenant,
il faut se prendre des mois
d'avance.
avec ça...
Les fam beaucoup
moins nombreuses qu'avant.
Il y en a certains qui ont même
les animaux, ça fait partie de
la famille, c'est leurs enfants,
donc ils sont beaucoup plus
sensibles, ils veulent vraiment
donner d
- Elle a vu Bowser plusieursfoie
2 ans. extrait les deux
canines du bas pour éviter
qu'il ait des problèmes à long
terme, donc ça, ça a été une
intervention. Ensuite de ça,
Puis, tout dernièrement, au mois
d'octobrait découvert
un souffle au coeur,
donc on vient de passer
pour pitou.
(rire)
Tourne!
une assurance médicale qui
lui coûte 90 $ pa
pour son chien. De plus en plus
de Québécois jugent nécessaire
- J'ai déjà eu des gens,
des factures, dans les centres
spécialisés, des 5000,
des 10 000, même. Les gens sont
vraiment prêts  plus
qu'avant.
(aboieme(aboieme(aboieme(aboiem)
- Et pas seulement pour
les soins médicaux...
(aboiements au loin)
- À l'Hôtel La Grange,
de Mirabel, la journée est
assez tranquille. Cet hiver,
les chies nombreuxs nombreuxs n,
un peu comme un CPE, offreun se.
Les affaires n'ont jamais été
aussi bonnes.
Hôtel La Grange pension canine
- Le télous a amenous a amenousé
beaucoup de garderies de jour,
parce que là, le chien passe
que ça empêche le propriétaire
de travailler comme il veut.
- On va aller voir Mario!
- Deux fois par semaine,
Coal, son Husky.
LILI BERNARD
- Le confinement fait en sorte
qu'une présence, c'est très
sécurisatant aussi, alors moi,
je suis venue porter Coal ici,ps
avec des amis, donc il
socialise, il dépense
son énergie.
- Elle paie 30 $ pour le fai
garder toute la journée.
50 $ si c'est pour la nuit.
À sesde prix.de prix.de prix.de.
- Moi, je trouve pas que c'esttn
membre de la famille, c'est
compté dans un budget. Alors
les dépenses au niveau des
loisirs,ferait pour
aller faire du ski, par exemple.
- Ici, c'est 5 étoiles, là :
les chiens, ils ont toujours de
l'eau fraîche à tous les
ils ont un bel enclos...
- La Grange offre d'autresservie
orthopédique de 30 minutes
à 20 $.qui sont plus
âgés, puis les gens sont prêts
à payer pour qu'on leur fasse
un petit massage pendant
- Mais ça, avez-vous uneformatit
des gens qui viennent?
- Non, ça va être de tendresse
et de caresses, là.
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'Hôtel MUZO, à Montréal,
avait été précurseur, en 2007,
en offrant la pension pour
chiens e pandémie continue de
lui amener de nouveaux clients.
LINDA ZAGO, propriétaire,
Hôtel MUZO
de demandes, d'informations...
- Et Linda Zago a diversifié son
offre. MUZO propose par exem
entraîneur canin.- C'est - C'ese
sur l'équilibre, sur le tonus
musculaire, on mus'ont pas
l'habitude d'être travaillés.
(aboiements)
- Ou bien un service de garde
- Là, il y a des activités
qui, justement, tr
un peu plus le mental.
Le chien... Alors, il y a
au cognitif, au physique,
à l'édue
est segmentée dans des petits
ateliers.
à Daniel Filion, fondateur
ne entreprise
qui donne des conseils
sur le comportement des chat
Éduchateur
- On est passés d'à peu près
400... 3ations
en une année, donc c'est
du jamais-vu.
adoptants, ce sont des premiersu
d'animaux, qui n'ont jamais eu
de chats, ils sont pas très,
très au courant de quels sont
les besoins du chat, et donc,ilc
des problèmes de miaulements
la nuit, on voit beaucoup ça.le,
des problèmes de pipi
hors litière et les problèmes
d'agression, c'est les trois
grosses problématiques qu'on a.e
ménages avec un chat, au Québec,
serait passé de 31 à 36 %.
La province compte maintenant
2,134 millions de chats,
soit presque deux fois plus
que de chiens.
- Statistiquement parlant,
on le voit, c'est 80 %de la clii
sont des femmes. Donc, on voit
beaucoup ça, où les femmes,
ça devient leur enfant,
ça devient un membre de
la famille à part entière.
- Son travail l'amène aussi
à évaluer certains produits
pour chats.
- Ça, c'est ce qu'on appe
des bols interactifs. Donc,
ça oblige le chat à travailler.
Donc, pour accéder à sa
nourriture, il doit sortir
la nourriture.
- Des accessoires parmi tant
d'autres. Au Québec, l'offre
de produits pour chats et chiens
explose.
DANNY BEaaaaaaaaaaaa
direction, Pattes et Griffes
- Depuis la COVID, là,
c'est toutes les semaines,
il y a de la nouveauté.
Ça peut être dans les jouets,
dans les laisses, dans
les vêtements, la nourriture,
les cannes... Tous, tous, il y a
des nouveautés.
- La chaîne Pattes et Griffes
vend maintenant jusqu'à 35 %
plus de produits danssins.
- On a plusieurs propriétaires
de franchises, en ce moment,
qui ont quitté leur emploi
pour pouvoir investirdans un Pa.
- Quand vous sortez d'ici,
ça fait des fois une grosse
facture?
- Oui, parce que j'ai chats aus.
- OK. Combien ça peut
vous coûter, là, par mois?
- Bien, mon chat... Mes chats,
c'est 100 $ par mois, puis lui,
c'est peut-être un autre 100,20.
- À eux seuls, les aliments pour
chiens et chats représentaient,
au Canada, en 2020, un marché
de 4,2 milliards de dollars.
PIERRE LEBLANC, DG, Mondou
- On est rendus à l'étape où
on veut pas juste bien nourrir
le nourrir
comme un membre valorisé de
la famille.
- Chez Mondou, qui va bientôt
compter 80 magasins au Québec,ss
impressionne.
- T'sais, ça, c'est un produit
dans le surgelé, là. Ici, on a
des côtes de boeuf. Il y en aqur
ça, ils vont nourrir l'animal
avec ça. Il y en a d'autres
qui vont dire : "Eille!
On veut donner une petite
gâterie, un repas spécial,
c'est son anniversaire."
- Des biscuits à la noix de
coco, aux bleuets ou au beurre
d'arachides, des croquettes pour
les articulations, pour la peau,
pour les dents ou pour calme
les animaux n'ont rien à envier
aux humains sur les tablettes.
- Le marché va être là,
parce que les gens vont
vouloir donner à leur animal
de compagnie la même chose
qu'eux ils vont manger.
Est-ce que leur animal
de compagnie en a besoin?
Le trois quarts du temps, non.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Chiens et chats perçus comme
des enfants... La SPCA vient
même de créer un contrat
de garde en cas de séparation,tn
avec un animal dure souvent plus
longtemps qu'avec un conjoint.